[Music]
you are going to be in a disadvantage in
the bot lane when you go against novelty
i think doublelift in many ways is close
to everything you want in an 80 carry
creates his life but it's doublelift
[Applause]
they've got three he always tells you
exactly what he's feeling
whether it's to his detriment or not i
feel bad for his van especially because
all the fans just say man the team was
so much better when doublelift was here
and it must make him feel like [ __ ] all
the time
he's gotten increasingly better of
towing the line between being risky
enough to deal damage
but safe enough to not die
a few more kills for doublelift on ash
is it the last shot
doublelift gets a peg to kill them
kill for this the one kill that's up for
double
you know somebody says i'm better than
you i'm like no you're not do they turn
around for the kill
haunts are fighting a minion almost on
down novel breaks up the prick ducktail
scion spartan and doublelift cleaning up
the crew
the janitorial duty onto dyrus that's
gonna go over to pobelter
no it's a triple kill for dusk
everyone else is trash
yang doublelift pang knows he's a
superstar
and isn't afraid to tell you about it
everyone else is trash
right here on the show everyone else is
trash after all he started his league of
legends career as a top level solo queue
player
and a streamer that players across the
lane feared
doublelift discovered his passion for
gaming at a young age with nostalgic
staples like star fox and goldeneye
on the n64 he also took interest in
magic tricks which is where he first got
his name
you show somebody in their card it's on
top you take that card you put in the
middle of the deck
and you just tap the deck and it's back
on top that's like the staple of
card magic essentially and that's how i
got my name
he then gained access to a machine that
would change his life
forever first came the likes of world of
warcraft and starcraft
and eventually league of legends
doublelift had met hotshot gg the
streamer and owner of counter logic
gaming
in early 2011 when the two duo together
in solo queue
and it was that relationship with
hotshot that eventually landed
doublelift a spot as a substitute on
clg's roster
oh my [ __ ] god doublelift
is a [ __ ] god he is god
he bounced from team to team early on in
his career and attended the first world
championship in 2011
as a support for epic games i can't
really hate
uh but he's gonna be uh you know oh cool
double lift
there we go yeah and yep there's
applause in the audience doublelift
gonna have
blitzcrank picked up but it was that
same love for games that led to the
first hiccup on doublelift's path to the
top
i didn't have any real life skills i
didn't have any like experience with
culture because i was pretty sheltered
growing up
so yeah i was i was pretty bad at life
i mean i didn't have any experience
doing anything except for sitting in my
computer and playing games
after a disagreement with his parents
left him without a place to stay before
college
he reached out to the league community
to find a temporary home
after a few dms on reddit a trip down
the california highway and some mac and
cheese
travis gafford and doublelift became
roommates
so i offered him a place to stay reached
out to him
and sent him a private message on reddit
and then didn't hear back from him and
so then the next day
he makes another thread that's like a
follow-up i posted in the thread and
then private messaged him again
all of a sudden you know i got off of
work it was the afternoon
that day and got a message from him i
was like that's great dude with hardly
any clothes or money to his name
doublelift joined unrestricted gaming
which later became team
curse being on curse they're a really
rich organization
and i just so lucked out i made guides
and i made content for them and i got
paid a lot of money
in november 2011 doublelift landed
himself a role that would go on to
define the early portion of his career
clg starting a.d carry the ult on him
but batoy flash auto attack double is
gonna get the kill under support here
comes the ezreal
not enough to kill double with the
lifesteal that's too big
ladies are not gonna be getting double
lift either and it was with clg where
doublelift became known as a force to be
reckoned with
foreign
he possessed the level of mechanical
skill and a proactive playstyle that
stood out amongst his peers
and of course an aura of confidence that
very quickly made him a fan favorite
i just really like the feeling of uh
shutting people up you know somebody
says
i'm better than you i'm like no you're
not that said doublelift never seemed to
forget where he came from and was widely
loved for his willingness to share that
with his fans
this experience that i've had in the
last couple years has changed me so much
like if i didn't do this i would still
be really sheltered and dumb about
everything
and i would never have the experience
like go out
and like have fans and just be like a
celebrity and just
travel across the world go to all these
new places meet all these people
i would still be really awkward i'd
still be really ugly and fat
clg were certainly a fan favorite team
early on and the fires of that fandom
were only further stoked
by their heated rivalry with team
solomid congratulations on your
win recently against tsm so i guess that
makes it
4-0 against tsm what makes them so easy
for you guys
well they're just free sm you know
doublelift quickly developed into a
franchise player by the time the lcs
started in 2013.
so much so that clg popularized the
protect doublelift strat where they
would literally draft a team composition
around feeding him we do have the
teleport coming in from chris is he
going to be able to get the twisted
advance on the double if they need to
shut him down
early on he's being caught up is he
going to die in the wild growth comes
through look at all those shields
first academy are trying to get onto him
the culling's there as well
they've wasted everything on doublelift
he's still on half health
clg's here link's on the other side
three balls shockwave
the dissonance destroying the ad carry
everyone on curse academy is melting
keane's wondering where the heck his
team went trying to kite through
clg there's the cocoon king's gonna go
down
that's the ace and that's gonna be baron
in preparation for that first lcs split
the team shuffled their roster quite a
bit and brought in aphromoo
a support player and streamer with a
large personality together they would
form one of the most potent bot lane
duos in na
oh there it is they're going for it the
exhaust goes down unexplained
the dazzle was there and the final hits
will be for doublelift first blood for
clg there's a flash
there it is the headbutt as well he's
gonna get oh wow they put
everything on him cleanser not and they
find the first blood coming in for
double lift
aphromoo was the shot caller the team
needed and his team first mentality
paired nicely with doublelift's
aggressive gameplay
while doublelift was your traditional
franchise player on the rift
there seemed to be something different
that separated him from other great n a
players
he had the kind of larger than life
personality that transcended the game
also congratulate you on your 500th
regular season kill in 100 games you're
the first player in the north american
lcs to do so how does it feel oh boy
cool that's awesome i'm the best
i already knew that doublelift was
hungry in an exceptional way
and when he flashed forward in the bot
lane it was the same way he'd bite back
in interviews or talk smack on the stage
i think other people they
didn't have to like fight to survive you
know like they didn't
like when i became a pro it was all i
had and it still is all i have because
if
i fail at being a pro and i'm not the
best and i'm not the most successful
then i feel like
i like left home for nothing i'm always
giving 100 because i know
i have nothing if this if my programming
thing is gone i'll just be nobody
clg made strides in 2014 but failed to
compete for the lcs title that hotshot
and doublelift so desperately wanted
and at the end of 2014 the organization
revamped their roster
clg and doublelift came out of the gates
blazing in the 2015 spring split but it
remained to be seen if clg could compete
with na's best when it came to playoff
time
and well it turned out they couldn't clg
was upset by team liquid in what was one
of the most heartbreaking letdowns
in franchise history but clg is such
a big brand here in the north american
lcs and again
they have undershot expectations in the
playoffs but
doublelift's journey with clg wasn't
done just yet
clg looks strong in the summer split and
primed to make another playoff run
balls goes down before being able to put
out anything a possible
pentakill here for doublelift that's a
triple meteos is closed chrono breaks
back
right in favor of quadra there it is a
few more kills for doublelift on ash is
it the last shot
doublelift gets a peg to kill shutting
down sneaky
after the dust from the regular season
settled clg received the first round bye
before sweeping team impulse with ease
to earn themselves a spot in the nalcs
summer finals at madison square garden
and staring back at them on the opposite
side of the rift was one of the most
storied teams in nalcs history
and clg's greatest rival team solomid
this is going to be a close series we
are very likely to go the distance and i
hope we do this is a rivalry that always
gets the fans hyped and has been a part
of the lcs well
since before there even was an lcs see
if he can help the team that's a big
win just right onto bjergsen three-man
shockwave where's the answer
tsm is not in the right position to get
the attacks on the priority targets
it's clg the table now to push them
right over in their own
command shock wave engage zion spartan
and doublelift
cleaning up the crew the janitorial duty
onto dyrus that's gonna go over to
pobelter
no it's a triple kill for double clg
completely cleans house and it all
started
with the prom q onto bjergsen in the
right spot
that kill going to them but dyrus has
also fallen that's going to be pobelts
are going down
way too close now for clg triple kill
for turtle
looking for the quadra not going to get
it that time it's a triple for
doublelift he's looking for bjergsen
double that's gonna clean one up 40
seconds on the clock boys
and the faithful shall be rewarded clg
take the inhibitor they're going to take
the nexus dirts
and they're going to take a trip to
worlds this is going to be it
counter logic gaming fighting every
season
since there has been one and now taking
down team solo made it madison square
garden
to be your 2015 summer split
champions
[Applause]
a well-earned trio by clg
clg were put through the esports wood
chipper for years
constantly playing the part of that
beloved team that could never quite get
there
but they did what they had to do and at
the end
rosa starr i'm speechless it's been
years of
blood sweat and tears for all of us
sorry my throat's shot um
but it's it's truly magical to be here
thank you
the kind of player that could define a
generation of north american league of
legends
the face of clg and north america's best
ad carry but the night that worlds 2015
ended
everything changed
hey my name is doublelift and starting
today
i'll be a part of tsm as doublelift
became one of the best players in the
league
his personality grew just as fast he
possessed the kind of untouchable
arrogance that you need to play with the
confidence he did
but it didn't stop when the nexus
exploded their in-game synergy was
undeniable but outside of the game
doublelift's strong personality had
taken its toll which prompted aphromoo
to make a call
afro went to the org and he said it's
either me or him
referring to me and i'm not playing with
peter next year over the four years like
i had a really negative attitude and i
would bring people down and i wouldn't
trust them i was loyal to the team and
i'd been sticking with the team for four
years
like this is a team that i grew with and
i was committed to grow with for
forever but the sad thing is like
honestly they weren't committed back
all bad blood aside doublelift had new
goals with a new team
i think our goals are in perfect
alignment
i just want to do the most that i
possibly can at an international level
and that's what andy and bjergsen
have promised me that their goals are
too he was kicked from his first ever
lcs team and joined their greatest rival
and showed everyone he'd do anything to
achieve his goals
tsm were always looked at as a domestic
super team of sorts
and pairing the likes of doublelift with
bjergsen gave north american
fans hope on the international stage
both tsm
and clg were humbled at worlds but
they've also both made some huge changes
in the off season
tsm in particular made a big push to
bring in a lot of high caliber starters
including fanatics veteran shot caller
yellow star as support
and one of the more surprising moves
clg's own long
time carry double lift but at the
beginning of 2016
doublelift and tsm did not look like the
powerhouse
everyone expected them to be and finish
that first split in sixth place
tsm's worst finish in lcs history if you
look at the plaques behind us tsm have
won
half of all north american lcs splits
they've won
they've won three three yeah and right
now they come into playoffs as the
lowest possible seed
nine and nine not the record you expect
when you pull these all-stars together
tsm
have to hope they can pull it back
together but they bounce back in a big
way come playoffs defeating both cloud9
and immortals on route to a clash
against a familiar foe in the finals
[Applause]
up from his ga spence going to try and
stop but he's here
that's it the ace for the dlc the
cleaner from stixxay
nclt you can change the players
but the faith remains the rage played
tristana from stixxay
put it all in his hands give him the
rapid fire
give him the resets and give him his
first ever north american championship
in his first season on clg
after a tough loss at the hands of their
biggest rival tsm were on a mission in
the summer split
they went 17-1 in the regular season
after adding biofrost
and followed that up with a near
flawless run to win the split
now can they have the follow-up damage a
couple of stuns come in
they've got bjergsen and they shut him
down with a 1600 damage grid
double blow meteos another knock of
trades his life but it's down
get the g.a definitely
the ceremonial taking of the nexus tour
it's nothing
to stand in their way as tsm
cement themselves as the most dominant
organization in north american league of
legends
and win their fourth north american
championship
now it's either c9 or immortals maybe
it's like maybe it's end
but those are the two you look at and
yes
tsm can rightly hoist that trophy
as the top dogs of north america with
tsm it felt a little bit less like the
doublelift show
and he became a more mature and team
focused player you guys already punched
a ticket to worlds
but you just stamped it first seed for
north america
you will be representing us at the world
championship
in that pool a how far
does this tsm go i could not have been
prouder of my teammates like everyone
stepped up to the plate when it really
mattered like i'm super proud to be able
to represent na
i'm really happy that i was able to play
in canada which was like in a long time
coming to have an esports event
and i'm just gonna do you guys proud
heading into worlds tsm were considered
to be the most talented roster
that north america had ever assembled
but once again they were simply
outclassed on the biggest stage
and failed to make it out of groups one
baron buff is available
the inhibitors being dropped once that
goes down roy will never give up
look to set their sights on the nexus
uzi gets himself the fourth
the nexus is going down and team solo
made
their hopes their dreams they're done
royal advance to chicago
it was no secret that tsm had gone all
in during 2016.
they knew they had to do something
different to make a market worlds and
their choice
was to practice more than any north
american team ever had
and well they were burnt out after we
lost in
2016 uh peter and andy
they they took me aside and they they
talked to me and peter said
oh spring sweet sucks i want to be i
want to be a streamer you know i'm going
to make a lot of money i'm going to rest
up and then i'm going to come back and
he really wanted me to do it and he said
you know if this is what you want to do
then
then you can we'll tank spring split or
we'll find the best suitable players
that we can but
didn't cross my mind for a second it
just the fact that we performed so
poorly in 2016 worlds
or at least we didn't perform near any
of my expectations i just couldn't see
myself taking
taking really any any time off at all so
he decided to leave tsm
and spend the immediate future streaming
i don't like to use the word burnt out
because i think it's pretty overused but
i have like been working tirelessly for
a quarter of my life
on this project on like fulfilling my
dream
and i will be taking a break for a
spring split but i do plan to come back
for summer
for as long as he's been a pro player
doublelift has maintained a relatively
consistent streaming life on twitch
and it's become synonymous with his
lifestyle all right let's [ __ ] kill
cutie pie
much like his bot lane counterpart
sneaky doublelift is the kind of
larger-than-life personality that has
managed to transcend professional play
he's loved on twitch for his trash talk
like how bad can you possibly be when
you think like it carries new [ __ ]
buffs
on this patch unbelievable his highlight
reel plays
and being the kind of player that fans
both love to watch
baby and love to hate thanks thanks for
the sub you love my [ __ ]
wait
[Music]
i just i need a i need to say these
names out on my head before
as you may have suspected with someone
who is as competitive as doublelift is
his break from the game didn't last long
i was
watching it i'm like this feels weird it
feels like i belong there
like it just feels weird to watch lcs
and i'm not a part of lcs he returned to
the lcs rift that same split in spring
2017
to help team liquid avoid relegation i
guess like
bringing doublelift at the last point
really helped us i feel like we would of
not make out of the relationship
a relationship relegation match with a
doublelift so
really thankful for him to saving my job
and then promptly returned to tsm
where he helped them win the summer
split tsm
cement themselves as the greatest team
north america has ever seen
six championships in ten splits they
have never missed a final
they have never missed worlds and they
are once again
your north american champions
[Applause]
but again at worlds it just wasn't
enough
on the day not just once though
tsm may have beaten them in the first
game this time
revenge is there for all of europe it
seems elation
four misfits for europe and
agony in defeat here for tsm again
out in group stages in worlds 2017.
last year same roster high expectations
not able to get past groups
unfortunately for doublelift this would
go on to become a defining
characteristic of his career
he's the single most dominant adcary in
nalcs history
and on paper a world-class talent but
regardless of his supporting cast
he has failed to make it outside of the
group stage in a riot-hosted
international event for as much as he
was defined by his massive regional
success
it was all mirrored by his failure to
make his mark on the world stage
and when 2017 came to a close doublelift
received shocking news
he learned he was being replaced by zven
on tsm
through a reddit post doublelift
returned to familiar territory during
the 2017 off season
that same team liquid squad he'd helped
avoid relegation were looking to
assemble a super team
and they wanted doublelift as for the
rest of tsm
um i'm planning on just destroying them
this whole year
i hope team liquid can have a perfect
record against tsm
[ __ ] on them in the finals if they make
it there i want to
absolutely demolish tsm's legacy and
make sure that they regret that decision
during the 2017
offseason the league adopted a franchise
model and what this meant for him was
quite simple
a lot of job security this is my eighth
season
and this one feels different because the
franchising the stakes are so much
higher
i have a lot more pride in being an
american player now especially like a
homegrown talent i guess
and in 2018 team liquid were exactly as
advertised
they had it all the swagger baron one
corner hp
very very impactful wanting to go over
the wall
oh my god and he gets out the teamwork
someday toe-to-toe oh those hyper hits
knocks him back flies forward and pole
belts are fast finger flashes out of
that gnar ultimate
the star power needs to out damage
impact pretty tankies all those in as
well megan has impacted into the wallace
definitely does finally get the sniper
combo
down to the trip reset jumpstare is a
pop from matt he's gonna just leave him
to
leave him for dead a huge massacre in
the bot lane three for one
and the ability to rally from behind a
lot of both still available here's come
to
tom kenz to rejoin the fray gents in the
front line gets rid of the wave clear
and looks like it's gonna be the big
play and a ball bouncer finds the
two-man shuffle they got the pull back
and two kills already liquid that was
absolutely beautiful
after winning their semi-final match
doublelift received some life-changing
news
tonight an orange county neighborhood is
in shock after a mother is murdered and
police arrest her son
for killing her this all took place here
at the corner of
windsong drive just before 10 30 last
night
30 year old yeeong peng seen in this
booking photo
is in jail tonight accused of fatally
stabbing his mom
and critically injuring his dad thank
you for calling mission hospital
patient information
hi my name is elian peng i'm the son
of the two adults who were stabbed
his older brother had attacked both of
his parents with a knife
resulting in the death of his mother the
tragedy sent the entire lcs community
reeling
when i found out that peter's
mom had passed away and then later once
i found out
the manner in which she passed my
immediate thought was how can i help
what can i do for all of our thoughts
with with doublelift
to see how he handles the emotions i was
worried
even if he said he cannot play i would
understand
but a week after his world was turned
upside down doublelift was back on stage
doing what he loved his story began
with him leaving his family
and then finding support from the
community and so for peter you know it
makes sense that one he would want to
compete
and two that the audience would support
him so much in that
i think the most practical thing when
you're going through something really
hard is just to try to move on but in
doublelift's mind playing in the finals
was never in question i remember that
one of the first things steve did was
like hey if you need anything like if
you don't want to play
then that's absolutely like 100 okay you
don't need to feel like indebted or
anything i was
i was i was like incredulous like what
what do you mean like i'm not gonna play
like why would i not
play it might be liquid who's found a
hundred people
on four man shuffle there goes expensive
able to go in able to find the bull
destroys ryu and that's one of your
carries already out of the picture 100
thieves and some trouble going to be
taken even lower afromoo already taken
down
it's a double for double lift someday
now the target on the front line a
double kill for double lift
ryu is the last man standing but he
shall not stand for long
they've all been to the final stage
before and now they'll be there
victorious together
as team liquid are your north american
lcs
spring split champions liquid would go
on to take down the spring title
and then the summer title ii a giant
knockback bricks 50
that's two more kills for tl a double
for dublin
that is disappearing in front of him the
next is open
there is no defense said scarad shows up
but the base will fall back-to-back
sweeps
tl's the best team in north america
at the mid-season invitational tl looked
to be one of the strongest n a teams
ever
and well they just didn't
not going to perform four in a row for
the mvp
of the european lcs and reckless and the
rest of the team
will send themselves to the knockout
stage they will extinguish
team liquids hope fnatic make it to the
top four
they're going to paris and this trend
continued in south korea
it's good to have high expectations
of your the teams that you want to see
succeed like
it's not acceptable that i go to worlds
every year as the first
seed and i [ __ ] the bed and i just i
never perform and my team never makes
out of groups
and yeah i mean jesus i didn't think i
was gonna get emotional actually oh
that's all right
no no but like i
like it's been eight years and i can't
do this thing but
i'm just i'm never going to give up so
that's what i want to say
in a year where the west made the
biggest impact it has ever made it
worlds with cloud9 reaching the semis
and fnatic losing to ig in the finals
liquid and doublelift supposedly
america's hope
were nowhere to be found
so far in 2019 doublelift and liquid
look
even more dominant than last year
they're the clear favorites to win the
spring split
and that familiar feeling of a potential
for international success
is present once again with the addition
of former world champion
core jj doublelift gonna come in for jj
and
and friends there we go on the hunt team
liquid looks to make their play they're
going to get olay away from deathly
first so we cannot use the devour to
save the 80 carry well coordinated well
done well played
it's two kills to team liquid double
polarized they're jumping on they will
take down the cinder that's jensen dead
also there from core jj finds a pretty
good set of knockoffs and double up
is left to free it here in the front of
the fight and ultimate impact will steal
the rest of the team fight
damn it back down but i think they'll be
able to finish off the kills rooney does
die that's an ace for team liquid
but that's only led to disappointment
historically
doublelift might just be the most
storied player in the history
of north american league of legends he's
the first player to win a trophy with
three different teams
he holds countless records and they're
gonna try it oh they went in too early
[Applause]
[Music]
and has shown a flare for the dramatic
that the esports world
craves it would feel good to come home
into the arms of you know all this hype
and fame that we
just got it would feel a lot better if
we just crushed these smug asians
but if we know anything about doublelift
as far as he's concerned
all that is trash everyone else is trash
right here on the show everyone else
is trash cause this kid who left home
was homeless
became the best player in the lcs but
could never win a title and then won
five titles and became one of the faces
of the league
never stops asking for more from himself
he's shown us the light doublelift
shutting down sneaky and we've seen him
in darkness
like it's been eight years and i can't
do this thing but
i'm just i'm never gonna give up so
there's just
one more mountain to climb
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button